Kids do their quiz show, their quiz.
How do you train?
It is.
First.
Second Kip.
True.
Sorry about that, Bob.
It's fine, Adrian. So, how is it going? How are you doing today?
It's busy, busy, busy, but that's just the normal. I'm doing all right. How are you?
I'm doing good, good. Yeah, Shiraj did mention that you are, we have some interviews aligned today, so pretty busy day for you, so.
Yeah, we are one of our on-site field guys is going to be retiring in November. So the on-site field analysts, like support specialists, is a pretty important role. Just because I mean, it's like the face of
Okay.
Mm.
face of the company, they deal, you know, they're going out and fixing issues. And so, got to make sure that I get the right individual in for it. I have one good interview and one bad interview, but I mean, you know how you know how that goes. So, no, it's I one of the candidates.
Mhm.
It seems very promising and he's also interviewing at another company right now, so I'm going to try to steal him before he goes over there.
Well, how's that, uh, how's that motorcycle?
Yeah.
Amazing. So, yeah, so it's 650 CC, so enjoying that speed, that throttle. So, yeah, we'll definitely plan some trip.
Um, let's see.
Maybe solo trips.
But I would, I have already asked my wife if she can accompany me, but let's see.
At the six, 650.
Yeah, 6:50.
Very nice. My side by side, I think, is a 7 or 800. So they are, they're fun, but also my side by side probably weighs another 1000 pounds more than your motorcycle. So
Yes.
Yeah, so it's heavy, yeah, so getting used to it, but...
Still fun.
Very nice. Cool. Well, I'm happy that you are enjoying that. It's because you have kids, right? You have older, older kids, right?
Yeah, I have 10 year old.
But...
So I think my wife would hurt me right now if I went and tried to get a motorcycle, but we also have another baby on the way. So I mean, it wouldn't take a while for her to hurt me right now anyways.
So.
But.
He's got all those pregnancy hormones and all that fun stuff.
Yes.
Yeah.
So how are the engineers doing? How they are doing good? Any areas of improvement?
Yeah, no, they are. They're doing good. I unfortunately had to miss our weekly check-in with him last week. So I had something come up. There was a stupid issue that that's why I had to cancel our check-in on Thursday last week and then spilled over into the next day. But no, they're both doing.
They're both doing good. I mean, they are, they're...
We're assigning tickets out to them. They are still getting in the hang of it. Abner seems to be, he's putting in a little bit more time than Grayson right now, but they're averaging out to be about the same. So I think that they're both doing, they're coming up to speed.
not as quickly as like Shirage or Santino, but I think they might have been some outliers versus the norm.
They will, so you can start pushing the tickets and I'm pretty sure they will start picking up the pace.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm not worried with or at their current capacity or we know what I'm seeing out of them right now. The questions that they're asking, they're good questions. When I, when we need them to look at something or if we assign them over a ticket, I don't usually get any questions, but like I said, if I do, they're good questions and
No, everything's been going.
I mean, that's the same. Feeling good.
OK.
Okay, yeah.
All right, so...
We can quickly jump into the PPT, the presentation, and let's have a look at the numbers.
Okay.
that I was able to capture. Okay, so let me know once you're able to see my screen.
I can see it.
Okay, once again, welcome to our weekly business review. This is for the last week, starting May 4th to May 8th. There is no change in the agenda. Check in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, way forward and recap.
Um, good feedback for Shiraj and Centino. They are and Centino is progressing well.
And we already discussed about gradually reducing Shirage's ticket load and relocate to Grayson and Abner to enable hands on learning and coaching support. Grayson and Abraham had completed their initial trainings and actively shadowing Shirage and also started handling tickets.
And thank you for sharing the CSAT for the month of April for Sriraj and Centinel. So from next month onwards, you will start getting the feedback for Abner and Kris as well.
Yeah.
In the action tracker, ASA level up, that was for Shiraj, so we can ignore that for now. It's going to be relevant. And the second one is the productive board reviews for Sentinel, Ebner, and Grayson that I will be doing to identify any process or technical gaps, and that will be, I will keep on doing the same till.
July, I mean, we do it for three months initial.
And these are the APIs we agreed.
Moving on to performance, Sentinel aspect of the pace is utilized admin seventy-six percent.
And he proactively reaches out whenever he's stuck. And this is his ticket data. He worked on 59 tickets and closed all. Still mostly working on the RMM alerts.
Kip.
And this is the utilization for Shiraj. He's been pretty consistent from the very beginning, 78%. He was able to maintain his utilization above 75 throughout.
This is his ticket data. He worked on 126 tickets and closed 82.
with the ticket closure rate of 65%.
And then we have Grayson. He was on off on a Friday due to that minor accident. So he was, his utilization had been 15%.
And this is his ticket data. So he worked on 21 tickets and closed 9. And that makes his ticket closure at 42%.
This is for Evaners. So he's again pretty low. There was a...
Starting from 15%, and then he reached out to twenty-seven. He, his, as you mentioned, his time is a little more than Crescent's, but...
Yeah.
And this is his ticket data. He worked on 18 tickets and closed 5. And his ticket closure is at 41%.
Way forward board reviews again for Sentinel, Grayson and Ebner to identify any caps and we'll continue to support.
Sentinel person, and picking up the pace and to start meeting the utilization of ticket closure targets.
This is the AI by design. You already aware this is the build it live for 2026.
I did send you and Daniel an email.
Yep, I'm trying to, I'm trying to coax him into that, so I'll keep you guys posted.
Yep, sure. Thank you.
And this is Team GPS, you know, our in-house application. We can skip that. So that's it. Any question?
Well...
No, it's...
I mean, it's just more of the same. I mean, we will get Edgar and Grayson up to speed. I know that will be quick. I mean, I mean, what I might end up doing is start throwing them into the fire and just start assigning a bunch of tickets their way and stuff they can work on, they work on. If not,
Yes.
Yeah, feel free.
No.
Yeah, feel free, sign the more tickets and I'm sure they will be able to.
Work on those all with we have Shiraj, we have Santino, so they have all the support and your team as well.
Yeah, absolutely. So regarding Shiraj, is that is that date that I proposed for him being the last day on our account? Is that something that we can work with? I mean, that is essentially 2 weeks in a day from today.
So.
Well, that is something not my call, so I need to check with the accounting team. And maybe we can discuss in our next meeting.
OK.
Yeah.
Yeah, if you want to, if you want to have Natalie hop in on the last one, I don't know what her schedule is like or whoever. I don't, she's not even our account manager anymore. Who's our account manager now?
I don't remember, but if we want to have if we want to have them hop in and we can talk about that. And then also just some of the contract renewal, stuff like that. So we can make sure that everybody's in alignment on that. We should be we should be good.
Yeah.
Okay, sure. So I will ask the account manager to reach out to you and then we can go from there.
OK.
Yeah, that sounds good.
Okay, so I guess it should be Natalie, but let's see. I will just verify them once again. And one more thing, I just wanted to send you an email as well. Grayson has requested and a week off. Oh, sorry, a PTO on 26th.
Of May.
Um, yeah, May 26th, post Memorial Day.
Okay.
Um, I believe it's his birthday, so...
I think that's okay. I mean, we'll give it to him.
Is.
Yeah.
Yeah, so thank you.
Yeah, shoot me over an email on that and I will, I'll just, you know, follow procedure here. I'll tell you approved. So, but then also I'll offer my team lead on that as well. So, okay, one request that I have for you is when, if Grayson, Abner, Santino,
The.
No.
Yeah.
or Shirage and however much longer we have them. If they're going to be off, can you also throw Kris hours on the email as well when you're letting us know?
Yeah, I was thinking the same actually, like the one, the day when you were on off, I sent you an email and Kris was checking with, so he was not aware. So, I, I, that's already on my mind, so I will do the thing.
Perfect.
Fantastic. Yeah, I mean, whenever whenever you send something out like about one of them being off or one of the meeting and PTO day, I always try to copy him in just so he's aware of what's going on. But if we could, yeah, I it that's just a that's not a problem or anything. I think it's more of a want than a need.
Yeah.
Sure.
Yeah, I understand. Completely understandable.
Nope.
Thank you, Adrian. Thank you for joining this call and have a wonderful rest of the day and week.
Two buddy, enjoy that motorcycle.
Yeah, thank you. Bye.
Where?